all right Sharon is up Sharon's with us
in New York or New York New York hey
Sharon how are you hi good um my husband
and I are debating if we should fight
for being pretty first of all thank you
so much we love your show
and we hope you can yeah it's bad around
there yes very bad very bad how much dad
have you got our household income is 7e
gross and I have $14,000 on the HELOC on
my house $80,000 and credit cards and
the car lease which is 420 a month I
have thirteen thousand on it okay what
in the world have you been doing these
credit cards why we're not sure it's
been dragged for four years because one
time we were very young and we didn't
make a lot of money and we lived on it
like food and things and instead of
covering it we just paid minimum and the
interest ate it up and now when we're
like woken up we have two babies and I
mean we can't turn the wheel back we
would do we didn't even know about you
back then we were a mess now wait how
many hours a week do you work
so maybe thirty six my husband works
full-time he's 60 gross and then 10k is
side jobs so we're doing we also have
two small babies at home okay so you're
at home
I'm at home now yeah I he's working he's
working thirty-six Mossad jobs I got
okay I mean I'm working also a few hours
a day I do it let me ask you this I
asked you this right quick if if you
sold the car and got rid of the fleece
and you just didn't pay the credit cards
what
that gonna do it's gonna run your credit
and they might sue you before you can
get around to paying them agreed so I
haven't been paying them we were seven
months do you agree with what I just
said it's I'm not gonna pay them they're
gonna do me yeah eventually maybe one of
them will so what if they do then you
would file but I don't you're not
bankrupt yet you're just scared so I'll
tell you what we're gonna pay for you to
go through Financial Peace University
and Ramsey plus I'll give you the whole
Ramsey plus membership for a year and
set you up with one of our coaches for a
free 15 minute discussion I think we can
walk you out of this you have to sell
the car though it's car stupid hold on
Kelly I'll pick up and we'll get you
signed up as our guest